hello look at the lobby GameSpot's
weekly hangout every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
Pacific right here on GameSpot calm I'm
your host Andy Dwyer hello to you
watching us live until watching us on
GameSpot calm or YouTube in the future
and with a big old review go up this
weekend mr. Peter Brown you spent most
of last week playing at 10 at 10
from Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
you bet
super excited about it I'm very excited
about it yeah I certainly fifty hours
playing it last week and I'm not ready
to stop playing it time soon at your
review end up on Sunday a great review
very spoiler free which I think a lot of
people appreciated I had you in mind
thank you and we're gonna keep it the
same way here today so we're got we've
got a master reviewer segment I got a
bunch of questions from people via
Twitter in the GameSpot comments and and
I'm skirting away from story stuff and
you're like gonna be the second like
protection yeah so if I ask something
that's even skirting a little bit just
you know just round it off and and keep
it nice in general okay round and before
I get into the questions for those who
haven't read the review yet what are
your sort of main takeaways from phantom
pain yyu ten out of ten what makes it
like anyt standing must play game I mean
middle Gear Solid 5 has a very big
legacy behind it right so it's it's both
a singular game and a game that fits
within the middle of a grand saga that's
been going on for almost thirty years
now so the game is it's on its own apart
from the other games it is a an
open-world action game that is filled
with so many thoughtful touches and you
can tell there's just like incredible
amounts of consideration that when it's
absolutely everything just the simple
act of moving feels great just looking
at the world is rewarding like I mean
every single moment I spent with this
game I I found something that just that
it struck me with awe like I it's
there's just so much to talk about and
then as a part of the Metal Gear saga it
delivers on so many things that people
are hoping for which is a connection
back to the very first game Metal Gear
that came out in 1987 before the Solid
series began the MSX games the MSX games
yeah and so I'm a big fan of open-world
games I've got to question my myself
what's it like exploring this world it
it's is it a game that's very linear
that you're going from base to base that
you know where you you're to go next or
does it feel like an open world that
you're discovering elements that you
might not have necessarily needed to
bump into there's a lot of immersion
stuff like you're describing you know
you sort of you go about this world and
you know you have a list of missions
that you can choose from that you know
new ones open up but you have multiple
to choose from and you can pick one or
the other and even when you pick one you
can fly in by chopper and you're only
certain landing zones so you have to
show up at a certain point of the map
and then travel to your base and when
you're doing that you encounter wildlife
that is aggressive or maybe you view
them as a resource that you can capture
and send back to mother base that's
another really big important aspect of
the game so there's a lot to do beyond
just here's a mission go for it I mean
when you're in the world there are so
many things to do that it's easy to
forget about what your mission is if you
really take in everything and consider
all of your options hmm is it surprising
to you that it's such a well crafted
open-world game considering totally
konami have ever done that well Kadima
productions have never done every single
medal your game has been you know like
missions set in very contained areas
with a linear path from one to the next
and it's phenomenal what they've done I
mean you know I think you can start with
a massive map and throw a character in
there and call it open-world and you
know that that is the case here in a way
but there are just so many things piled
on top of that that skeleton of what
defines an open-world game that I was
totally blown away I mean this game has
been in production for five years and
you know it shows I mean there it's
there's never a shortage of things to
look at or do and it's it's incredible I
don't get into the user questions as
quickly possible because we've got a
bunch of them here first one then from
final show friend of ours at BC plasma
asks is there a reason to explore around
in open world what kind of collectibles
can you get in Metal Gear Solid 5 so all
of the equipment and technology that you
unlock and develop in the game happens
back at mother base which is an offshore
base where you were sort of building a
private military and throughout the open
world you find natural resources you
find wildlife you find people of all
things and all of these can be collected
and sent back to your mother base so
you're incentivized to collect those
because all of them go into you know
research and development of new
technology which isn't necessary to to
beat
you can skirt by with almost a bare
minimum throughout the whole thing but
you have to be incredibly good in order
to do so
so you're incentivized to collect things
to develop new tech to make your life
easier but it also makes the game much
more varied and interesting because some
of the tools you all knock are so crazy
and they just they may be a sense of
like Wonder and joy you know from like
this little thing you add to your arm
lets you punch the ground that sends out
a sonar wave I mean it's yeah so there's
there's plenty to collect and there's
plenty of reasons you collect that stuff
excellent and do you sort of decide what
you're upgrading during that it's not
like if you get like seven if you Fulton
aged goats you get like some sort of
special goat armor no so essentially
when you collect enough resources let's
say you collect enough people right that
levels up a certain part of your base
wherever you place them in a certain
field of development hmm when you hit
that level in that field it then unlocks
the ability to to craft a thing but then
to actually craft it you use the natural
resources and the money that you earn
like okay I wish it's sweet it's a it
actually kind of reminds me of XCOM yeah
where you're like putting people in
specific places yeah and then what you
collect that on the fields your
translate that's pretty cool John class
on Twitter asks I paid all the Metal
Gear Solid games except for is there any
important information and from one that
I should know heading in so I guess the
sort of wider question to that is can
you enjoy this game without having sort
of an encyclopedic knowledge of those
four games or maybe MSX ones and if
there was one or two games that you need
to know more about which ones would they
be one of the great things about this
game and I think what was really smart
of Kojima to do is to create a story
that is interesting enough in its own
right without the connections to games
from the past or games set and you know
in the future in the timeline a large
chunk of the story is dedicated to this
specific thing that anybody can get into
I think the cinematography the voice
acting and the writing are all so good
and like yes it's ridiculous like the
things that happen in this game make no
freaking sense but the the the emotions
that are conveyed in the voice acting
and the the trauma that these characters
endure that you watch sort of culminates
a new experience that you can enjoy just
on its own you don't have to really play
the other games do you but if you have
the sort of last section of the game
really does reward
all that dashing yeah for a series that
spent like you know almost three decades
long it did it feel like a like an
incredible and did you want to like
immediately grab somebody else who play
the game and like talk about it oh it's
absolutely but I would say that I think
a lot of people are expecting that this
game will sort of answer very specific
questions and tie things up in a really
tidy box but if it answers a lot of
questions but at the same time I mean do
we really want to know everything about
these characters I mean so much fun
about the series is speculating
speculating about their origins their
motivations their relationships
Kojima must know that because the ending
to this game opens as many new questions
as it answers Wow so I yeah yeah that's
let's top it there and I guess then for
for people who don't maybe you said that
like obviously the game is enjoyable in
its own right does the does the game go
to any lengths to try and like fill in
information like give you a little bit
of catch ups via codecs or via like
story aside yeah remind you what was
going on yeah you collect cassettes in
the wild cassette tapes and you you earn
them as rewards for certain mission and
those contain tidbits of the past the
game also gives you a bit of a preamble
to let you know what happened like
leading up to Ground zeroes and in
ground zeroes which was the prologue to
this game so it does inform you a little
bit about the story leading up to it
the stuff that comes afterwards that is
not spelled out so much there is some of
that towards the end of the game where
they reveal like sort of the result of
the outcome in this but yeah you know it
doesn't it's not like you have a huge
compendium of information to like sort
through which I guess you also never
really had in the old games either you
there was an element of like going
online and trying to figure bits and
bobs I mean yes Metal Gear Solid 4 had
this like incredibly large optional
database of information to install that
is an encyclopedia for the series more
or less so yeah I mean no game the
series has really gone to the lengths to
tell the entire saga but I think this
does a good job for people who are
curious there is stuff to dig your teeth
into cool and next one up Daniel Moss at
Dino's at sky war on Twitter asks have
you tried the PC version any chance of
another Arkham Knight type scandal
what version did you play how long do
you play do you play the PC version No
so who knows no I played the PlayStation
4 version for just about 50 hours and
you know the game holds up incredibly
well technically one thing I did notice
it has really great draw distances and
you sort of land in a huge environment
and you really do appreciate like wow
like I can see so far to the distance
and things look great while you don't
see pop it in the distance on the ps4
version you do see some in the
foreground hmm
but I think the fact that you have so
much to gawk at that's that's larger and
more impressive you know that sort of
distracts you from the little blade of
grass like a foot a foot ahead of you
that maybe didn't pop up yet yeah and I
think it's a good trade-off but speaking
of the PC version if you look at Ground
zeroes that game is phenomenal on PC it
just looks I mean the console versions
look wonderful anyway the PC version is
just amazing and this is done in the
same engine it's for all intents and
purposes the same you know build of a
game you know in a way so I would expect
the PC version to be great I haven't
tried it yet but that's what I expect
cool I will you be trying it next week
when it comes out I don't worry attacks
on when I come when the game comes out
or document oh you're not going and I
gone attacks this is sticking around
thing more like assault they actually
yes [ __ ] a little bit and Kay Donder
asks via Twitter how hard was a mega
solid five moderate difficulty to
hardest points was any parts we found it
difficult or there are absolute
difficult points towards the end of the
game especially and this is one of the
issues that's probably the only issue I
had with the game is that as you
approach the end of the story
normally you beat a story mission you
unlock a new story mission that natural
progression but what happens at the end
of the game is the game forces you to
play older missions at extreme
difficulty oh wow and you have to do
that in order to unlock new ones in my
mind that's to pass the time it does
sort of throw off your sense of
progression in a timeline because you're
like I did that you know 20 hours ago it
doesn't fit in the story if I'm trying
to do that again is it more difficult
because the point is it's more difficult
no because they it's like total stealth
like the moment the enemy is alerted we
fail the mission you know or you have no
equipment like you basically go in here
like
very sort of versions of them yeah some
of those you can cheese like you do
getting the ability to to call in air
raids those cost resources and it lowers
your ability to reach a certain level of
rank right um but yeah if the going gets
tough you do have tools at your disposal
be at that or you know one of the
buddies you can take with you makes life
much easier and yeah so the game is hard
but it gives you the option this to make
it easier on yourself if you simply just
want to beat it and continue cool a
couple more questions here
Vova asks does the open world nature of
the game play translates to or impact
the story so I guess the sort of take
from that would be do these feel like
isolated missions you're kind of walking
to and from a does does the choices you
make in the open world bleed into the
story at all like can you do like only
this mission and it changes the story
someone well I think the open world does
for this game which I don't know if this
is answering this question specifically
but it gives you a lot of time to spend
with big boss hmm and you know as you
sort of feel a connection to the events
he's going through that ends up being a
lot of time with yourself and your own
thoughts and if you consider that he is
the main character and this is a story
surrounding him the fact that you have
the time to reflect on what he's going
through where he is and what he's doing
to me lends itself lends a good
connection between the open world and
the story mission because if this was
just a story and the gameplay was just
there to support it it would be more or
less a movie but this game is unlike
something you know some people pointed
at melior Solid four and they were like
there's like 20 hours of cutscenes like
this you know the gameplay stuff is on
the secondary here this really is about
being in the world that exists as the
character and so I think that the
open-world is actually a great stage for
big boss and that's the story at large
yeah another great aspect of this series
of course is the sort of the cinematic
and quality of its presentation and
certainly the cutscenes especially in
but I guess the whole series going
through like Metal Gear Solid 1 was
known for it for was was pretty
incredible and had his five stack up in
terms of that aspect of it are we
looking at 15 20 minute long cutscenes
that could have been shorter or does it
feel like it's been well directed and
edited there are cutscenes that you may
say or 15 minutes roughly but you know
those come at certain beats when you've
been struggling really hard to
accomplish something and get to a point
in the story and those are a reward in a
big way because you are fighting to
understand what is happening next and
considering that the the high quality of
the framing composition the voice acting
the lighting I mean even just down to
the the art style like these cutscenes
are great and you know there there are a
bunch of them but you spend the majority
of your time playing this game rather
than watching it cool last question I
think one or two more maybe and first
one this one sort of an amalgamation of
a bunch of questions people have asked
Devon hall asks where do you see the
series going post Kojima if at all where
will we go for Akron isms and movie chat
does this feel like does this feel like
the last Metal Gear game from what you
played like regardless of story wait
does it or without tipping on the story
does it feel like there this is wrapped
up and we'll have Kadima making
different games from their own uh I do
not believe Kojima will be making
another Metal Gear game I don't see how
that's going to happen giving the
politics at Konami and given the place
in the story and honestly the scope and
scale of this game it's the amount of
work that's gone into this is is
immediately apparent and it never fails
to remind you of the fact that this is
this is his opus this is like a an
amazing body of work and it's I don't
think we'll ever see a game like this
from Kojima in the Metal Gear universe
ever again and last question no spoilers
do you feel ashamed of your words and
deeds uh of my words indeed remember the
Twitter the tweets at Kojima said about
oh why us Oh without getting into us
okay there's there's justification in
the story but it wasn't necessary okay
fair enough
I'm Peter Bryan thank you so much going
on Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
review up on GameSpot calm right now if
you want to check it out go over there
and let us know what you think in the
comments below
you